Deutschland ist raus weil Spanien
verloren hat aber ganz wichtig guckt
euch das erste Tor von Japan an hätte
das zählen dürfen mehr als eine halbe
Million Follower hat Pascal Martin 25
Millionen likes Pascal ist ein tiktok
Star der erste Schiedsrichter in
Deutschland der das geschafft hat
Spitzname Qualle das kam so als Pascal
noch zur Hauptschule ging halt ihm ein
Lehrer erklärt woher sein Name kommt aus
dem Französischen Pasquale spricht
Qualle der Instagram und tiktok Star
würde sie sagen einen tiktoks da so ich
bin einfach ein Mensch der versucht im
Fußball was zu ändern ich würde mich
jetzt nicht ich will mich nicht auf eine
Rampenlicht stellen und nach vorne
stellen und so auch wenn das so ist das
ist von alleine gekommen aber ich will
er derjenige sein der etwas ändern
möchte an an den an den Hobby
Schiedsrichter und am Fußball Qualle
wirbt für Meer Respekt und Fairplay auf
dem Fußballplatz noch nie mussten so
viele Spiele abgebrochen werden wie in
der vergangenen Saison Ausschreitungen
und Gewalt im Amateurfußball quer durch
alle liegen und Altersklassen Qualle
guckt sich das nicht länger taten los an
schon mit seinem ersten Video über sich
und seinen Job als Schiedsrichter fing
alles an ich hatte ein Spiel gehabt
C-Jugendspiel und ich habe einfach mal
gedacht kommen du nimmst heute einfach
mal ein bisschen deine Sachen mein Handy
auf hab mein Handy genommen habe ein
paar Videos von dem Platz gemacht habe
ein paar Videos in meiner Kabine gemacht
habe mich ein bisschen gezeigt habe
meine Schere Klamotten bisschen gezeigt
habe das Ganze am Abend auf tiktok
gestellt bin am nächsten Morgen
aufgewacht voll zur Arbeit fahren guck
auf tik und dann Bumm auf einmal eine
Million Aufruf ich denke so alter was
sind jetzt hier passiert ne hat die
Leute interessiert und das hat mich so
also ich war begeistert gewesen ich
dachte so boah krass und dann habe ich
damit angefangen Woche für Woche immer
weiter immer weiter und dann habe ich
mich mit den Equipment weiter gesteiger
nach oben hin äh Kumpel dazu geholt der
das ganze auch besser gefilmt hat also
da nicht mehr mit dem Handy und dann
ging das quasi immer Stück für Stück
weiter nach oben sieben Geschwister hat
Qualle keine unbekümmerte Kindheit nach
dem Hauptschulabschluss zwei
Ausbildungen beide abgebrochen zunächst
zum Kinderpfleger dann zum
Einzelhandelskaufmann zu seinem
Stiefvater hat er eine besondere
Beziehung
also ist Qualle zu ihm gezogen Frank
Elfers ist Pascals Vater Kumpel Manager
Fahrer Leibwächter und Berater in einem
ich habe damit mein Stiefvater viel
gesprochen brichst du deine Ausbildung
jetzt ab oder machst du es nicht böse es
jetzt ab oder machst du dich aber ich
dachte so er Pascal du liebst einmal im
Leben du hast es jetzt gerade diese
Chance ich habe meine Ausbildung
abgebrochen habe mich selbstständig
gemacht habe eine Firma gegründet habe
einen Gewerbe angemeldet und zack das
hat gut funktioniert ich stehe jetzt gut
da und bin froh dass das ganze auch so
geklappt hat weil es hätte auch in die
Hose gehen kannst sag ich mal aber eine
Ausbildung kannst du immer machen muss
ich dazu sagen qualles Stiefvater hat
vor seinem Schützling dem 20-Jährigen
Jungs da einen heiden Respekt
er ist absolut geradlinig geht seinen
eigenen Weg egal was von außen auf ihn
einprasselt an Kommentaren oder so
erhält daran fest und ja lebt sein Traum
ja andere träumen er lebt seinen Traum
wie kommt ein Tini auf die Idee
Schiedsrichter zu werden Qualle war
schon mit
13c-jugendtrainer und als Trainer hat er
ab und zu auch mal ein paar Spiele
gepfiffen und dann sich selbst gesagt
Pascal das was macht ihr so viel Spaß
probier's doch mal aus mach doch mal so
eine Schere Ausbildung und guck mal wie
das einfach funktioniert und was
natürlich auch ein Grund ist ich kann
einfach nicht Fußball spielen also wenn
ich den Ball hatte dann dann muss man
sofort dabei das gleich weg so richtig
ich ich Fußball spielen kann ich
überhaupt nicht also da bin ich raus ich
kann nur laufen der Spaß kann einem als
Schiedsrichter schnell vergehen
heutzutage immer lauter und heftiger
werden die Anfeindungen auf dem Platz
aber immer weniger Zuschauer und Fans
wollen sich damit abfinden in den 80er
Jahren riefen unzufriedene Zuschauer
noch Schiedsrichter ans Telefon
auch heute ist der Ton rauer viel rauer
bleiben wie zum Beispiel [ __ ]
Bastard du Arschloch fick dich geh
sterben auch Morddrohungen kommen auf
wie ich auf im Internet bekomme also es
kommt schon sehr viele Beleidigungen und
sehr oft machen sich die Leute gar nicht
Gedanken darüber aber ich bin ein Mensch
oder wir Menschen wir nehmen sowas auch
mit nach Hause so ne ich wenn ich abends
im Bett liege und ein Vater hat am Tag
zu mir gesagt boah ich hoffe du
verreckst auf dem Rückweg was auch
vollkommen was auch Leute zu mir sagen
dann will ich nicht zu Hause im Bett und
mach mich darüber witzig so dann dann
dann macht das was mit mir ich habe dann
auch vielleicht ein bisschen Angst oder
mach mir Gedanken darüber weil ich bin
wie gesagt selber auch noch jung ich bin
20 Jahre immer öfter bleibt es nicht bei
Provokationen und Beleidigungen dann
eskaliert die Situationen das kommt zu
körperlichen Angriffen Qualle musste das
am eigenen Leibe erfahren ich war
Schiedsrichter hatte ein Spiel gehabt
zwischen zwei Mannschaften die in der
Tabelle sehr aneinander standen und
beide wollten gewinnen war glaube ich
sogar auch ein Derby gewesen und war
eine B-Jugend also eine Mannschaft wo
auch die Jungs in einer Pubertät sind
also wo die auch mal für den ein oder
andere mal so ein bisschen austicken sag
ich mal habe eine Einspieler eine rote
Karte gegeben nachdem man mich beleidigt
hat und erst dann auf mich zugekommen
habe mich am Kran gefasst habe mich nach
hinten gestoßen und meinte zu mir würde
mir quasi was antun wollen und für mich
war das in dem Moment ein sehr schwarzer
Moment ich bin in die Kabine quasi
gerannt oder gegangen habe mich erstmal
eingeschlossen im ersten Moment und habe
das Spiel abgebrochen und bin dann nach
Hause gefahren zwei Monate hat Qualle
gebraucht um drüber wegzukommen und
wieder auf den Platz zu gehen doch diese
Krise hat ihn stärker gemacht heute
leitet er ein Spiel in der Kreisliga
C-Jugend 13 bis 14-jährige also wir
versuchen noch ein Bundesliga Niveau zu
sein das ist irgendwo richtig weil so
macht immer viel mehr Spaß dass man es
mehr mit mehr Power dabei und so ähm wir
versuchen das schon alles so zu machen
wie ist auch eine Profil liegen ist aber
ähm wir sind halt 30 Grad trotzdem und
dennoch vier Cheats und Linienrichter
und 28 Ordener werden gleich auf und um
den Platz herum zu sehen sein
rekordverdäch sich für ein Jugendspiel
bei Qualle das Spiel auf tiktok beworben
hat es richtig viel los beim
tuskartenhausen im Kreis Lippe trotz des
schneeregens also normalerweise gibt es
50 bis 60 Zuschauer aber jetzt durch
Qualle schätzen wir sind so an die 300
Zuschauer alle hier wissen es geht um
Respekt sich gegenseitig achten und fair
miteinander umgehen auf und neben dem
Fußballplatz auf dem heute mal der
Schiedsrichter der Star ist
er ist empathisch einfühlsam er geht auf
die Spieler gut ein es redet mit denen
auf Augenhöhe macht das nicht alles so
von oben herab reden weil er viel
Jugendliche pfeift und die die mögen
nehmen dann sowas ernst als wenn du die
jetzt wie so ein Erwachsener behandelt
ich finde Pascal ist mega engagiert was
vor allem die Jugend angeht also der hat
einen sehr sehr großen impact auf die
Jugend immer ein Bezug drauf und
versucht halt in eine gewisse message
message zu verbreiten damit er halt eben
diese Jugend im Fußball also
gewissermaßen inspiriert
irgendwie schafft Qualle es alle unter
einen Hut zu bringen das
Schiedsrichterteam die Ordner die
Spieler die tik tok-fan-gemeinde Jung
und Alt im Publikum
für das auch gut dass du das so mit den
Schiedsrichtern macht so dass er die
sage ich mal motiviert und ja dass man
die Schiedsrichter mehr respektieren
sollte er macht gute Videos finde ich
ist immer spannend das zu gucken so wie
er pfeift und wofür steht da
Schiedsrichter sollten respektiert
werden egal in welcher Liga egal wie alt
also sollte respektiert werden er sagt
halt auch öfters mal ja so werde
Schiedsrichter und so und das ist halt
schon gut ne weil Schiedsrichter gibt's
nicht so viele nicht viele Fußballer
wollen Schiedsrichter machen weil er
halt sehr viel auf dem Platz gehatet
wird und so und ja also ich finde das
persönlich sehr gut da wird einem fast
schwindelig so viel Lob und Anerkennung
davon können Bundesliga-Schiedsrichter
wohl nur träumen
in diesen Umkreis ist er halt glaube ich
der berühmteste Schiedsrichter und ja
halt das halt in dieser Zeit zu viel
erreicht hat das echt krass und er hat
auch sehr viele Leute darauf motiviert
halt selber Schiedsrichter zu werden ich
finde gut
dass alle macht einfach besonders weil
er
wird bei den Jugendlichen und Kindern
auf dem Fußballplatz hat und er ein
unheimlich gutes Talent hat auf das
jeweilige Alter einzugehen und die
Situation den Kindern auch auf dem Platz
zu erklären und er behandelt tatsächlich
auch alle auch nach dem Spiel wie ein
guter Kumpel und ähm ja die können
einfach zu ihm auch kommen und er ist so
ein anfassbarer Star für die Kinder und
das ist einfach toll toll findet das
auch der regionale Fußballverband dank
Qualle melden sich immer mehr
freiwilliger als Schiedsrichter im
Landkreis Lippe ganz entgegen dem
bundesweiten trennt
das bei uns im Kreis noch in den
Nachbarkreisen tatsächlich so dass
einige Schicht da immer mehr Sicht bei
den Anwärter Lehrgang anmelden auch mit
bewusst den Kommentar dass sie ihn
gesehen haben dass sie das cool finden
dass sie auch dadurch erst überhaupt
noch das Thema gekommen sind weil das
ist ja auch so ein Thema gerade bei
Jugendlichen sowas von mir auch also man
spielt Fußball man kommt ja gar nicht
darauf dass es auch sowas wie
Schiedsrichterei quasi ja gibt in dem
Alter und er macht dadurch ja so Werbung
dass die Leute darauf aufmerksam werden
sagen oh ja das ist ja auch was
interessantes und machen das dann mal
rund ums heutige Spiel ist alles gut
gelaufen apropos gelaufen ein paar
Flitzer konnten die Ordner dann doch
nicht daran hindern über den Platz zu
laufen die konnten wohl nicht anders
wegen all der Kameras am Fußballplatz in
kartenhausen
dann ja aber ich wollte ja erst flitzen
und ja die Mädels haben gesagt nee nicht
nackig nicht
zurück bei Qualle zu Hause so meine
lieben Freunde wann ist für euch
eigentlich abseits ich bin gespannt was
ihr dazu sagt ich werde natürlich alles
angucken also schreibt gerne in die
Kommentare rein er kann offenbar gar
nicht anders er muss einfach für den Job
als Schiedsrichter Werbung machen traut
euch geht auf dem Platz drauf und nimm
auch noch Verantwortung wenn ich als
Zwölfjähriger so eine Verantwortung
trage dann macht das auch was mit mir
als Mensch dann dann ändere ich mich ich
war damals so gewesen ich konnte mich
nie vor einer Kamera setzen ich konnte
nie flüssig reden ich hatte immer Angst
ich war immer schüchtern gewesen
heutzutage stelle ich mich vor 1000 von
Leuten und kann reden und kann und kann
labern wie ich will einfach weil ich das
gelernt habe durch dieses schizo der
Tätigkeit und das ist meine Mission ich
will etwas ändern das Thema respekt das
soll bei mehr Menschen einfach ankommen
weil es ist untergegangen und das ist
einfach das traurige ich schaffe es aber
nicht alleine aber ich versuche andere
Menschen damit irgendwie zu erreichen
dass sie mir dabei helfen Qualle
erreicht vor allem Kinder und
Jugendliche über das Internet und das
macht die Erwachsenen neugierig welche
mir die Zeitung nehme würde ich in die
Hand nehme passt Karl Martin tiktok Star
inzwischen gibt es Schiedsrichter
Influenza was ist ja auch selten gibt so
der 20-Jährige ist ein tiktoks da macht
auf youtube seine Videos macht auf seine
Videos dann weiß ich mache alles richtig
weil die Leute sehen das und das macht
Aufmerksamkeit es schlägt ein und dann
das das freut mich einfach fußball ist
sein Leben Qualle ist natürlich auch ein
waschechter Fan Arminia Bielefeld spielt
da die Hauptrolle wenn er gerade mal
nicht pfeift oder online ist man nehmen
nur die Daumen drücken dass er
nachhaltig Erfolg hat mit seiner Mission
mehr Respekt auf den Fußballplätzen in
Deutschland